- I'm sorry I was looking
at Dr. Mike's legs
and I'm like, he kinda thick.
What you think about that?
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
Welcome to another episode of
Responding to your Comments.
You might be wondering where am I?
So am I.
What happened to the YouTube space?
This makes me feel good.
- I'ma cover the whole outside
of my house in this material.
- Chill.
Gonna be a star, movie star, yeah!
(upbeat music)
All right, I said in my 50 facts video
that I have a problem with my fat thighs
and it's hard to find good fitting pants
because of this problem.
And then when I do my
video with my nephews,
who I was so excited for you to see them,
the only thing you guys could talk about
were my fat thighs.
I feel like I should just do a video
where it's just my thighs
for like 38 minutes.
People with fat thighs need love too.
(chuckling)
Lieutenant Salamander, Slamander?
Is it save to wear seven
watches on one arm?
You betcha.
Oka Ruto, can you talk about forms
of birth controls and their side effects
and especially what the best
protection is for teens?
I feel like many schools, including mine,
are still not teaching enough
about these kinds of stuff.
Generally the way that I talk about it
with my patients is on
an individual level.
What is it that they're looking to do,
what are they looking to prevent,
what risks are they taking
that I should be thinking
about in the back of my head
when I make a recommendation.
And then, I print out a little paper
that has some of the
options for birth controls
as well as the percentages
of how well they work
with perfect use and then usual use,
because they're not the same thing.
I ask them to read it and then come back
so we can discussion about what they read,
which one's their favorite,
what do they think they want to do,
each person has their own needs,
each person has their
own medical conditions,
each person's taking
their own different set
of medications and supplements.
I can't just give a generalized best type
of birth control recommendation,
'cause it matters.
Comfort Vanessa Mwaitsi Khabongo,
Doctor Mike, what are your
views regarding human cloning?
Do you support it?
If yes, would you want to get cloned?
Human clothing, clothing,
cloning scares me
because I've watched a
lot of Sci Fi movies.
Now this is not a medical opinion,
this is not a scientific opinion.
I mean could you imagine if there was
another Dr. Mike right here?
Yeah, what's the problem, bruh?
That's why.
Valerie Tucker, do you
think high school students
are chronically sleep-deprived?
Taking into account when we go to sleep
and when we have to be up for school.
I think the answer to that is yes,
and I think schools have already started
to take notice of this by
making classes start later.
When you're in your teenage years,
it's natural that you're gonna go to sleep
a little bit later because you wanna
be rebellious and cool,
you wanna play Overwatch,
get on Master's Level like myself,
when you have to wake
up and five, 6:00 a.m.
And you're going to sleep at midnight
that's not enough time for you to recover,
to reset your brain, to
get your hormones going,
to rest your muscles,
it's just not enough.
So what I recommend to
high school students
is eight to 10 hours of sleep.
This is more than when you become an adult
then I say aim for seven to nine.
Liyah, Doctor Mike, Doc
Mike, go see your doctor.
(laughing)
Yes, I often say that you
should go see your doctor.
Because, if you're gonna ask me about
a specific, specific problem,
I can give you a general answer
about what the problem could be,
what you should be on the lookout for,
what are scary symptoms, this and that.
But, I can't give you individual advise.
And most of the time, the
best advice I can give you
is to go see your doctor.
'Cause that's what my
job in this channel is,
it's to educate you to
make better decisions,
to feel comfortable to
speak with your doctor,
to see that we're humans too.
We make mistakes, we
sometimes say we don't know,
we have fun, we laugh, we have dogs,
we have furry walls.
Maggie Dergantz, if a
patient has painted nails
how do you check them properly?
I ask them to take the nail polish off
or I ask them to come
in the following time
with no nail polish on.
It's obviously not ideal,
and it's also not of utmost importance
if you have, for example,
a very healthy patient
that otherwise has no issues.
Vannah, How can somebody become a doctor
if they're not good at science or math?
If you have a natural curiosity,
there's always a way to get good at it.
And I don't even know
specifically why you're
talking about math, unless
you're practicing anesthesia
or something very specific.
Limited math skills are
needed to be a good doctor.
Evelina Calin, is it true that women have
a higher pain tolerance than men?
I don't know if I've ever heard that
for a research standpoint.
I could see why someone would say that,
because women deliver babies and that
is obviously a very painful experience.
Gory Bakr, I keep eating
chips, parentheses Pringle's
am I dying?
(laughing)
That's carbs that you don't need,
that's a lot of salt you don't need,
you're gonna get all puffy and weird.
Don't do it.
Don't do it, don't do it.
Lena Fazzolari, merch, where's the merch?
Ah man, I've been saying that
for the longest time, I
promise I wanna make merch.
I'm more looking to figure
out the trademark situation,
so as soon as that gets figured out
I promise you're gonna have merch.
I'm gonna be wearing it on the channel.
Cameron Harvey, are fart
needles a real thing?
I'm googling it.
Someone wrote getting the fart needles,
I'm watching this.
- [Son] Are you getting
the fart needles again dad?
- [Dad] Never mind what I'm gettin'!
- I have no idea what fart needles are.
But please, describe to
me in the comment section
what the heck a fart needle is.
Asia Tomaszewska, hi Doctor Mike,
is the sauna good for our health?
Oh, I feel like we
should get Rhonda Patrick
on the show, she's a big sauna supporter.
I'll tell you this, in
the home were I grew up,
in Staten Island, my dad has a sauna.
We use it all the time.
When I go to the gym, I use the sauna.
I do think there are health benefits,
obviously that's something that's
very, very difficult to study
because it's difficult to do
in a controlled, randomized environment.
Correlation studies have shown some pretty
impressive health benefits to those,
when you compare those who
use saunas to those who don't.
And, you see that effect go up based
on how often they use the saunas.
So it's dose dependent,
which shows that it's
probably has something
to do with the sauna,
gets me really excited about
it because I love saunas.
I think it's really relaxing.
Just don't fall for all of that,
it helps you release toxins, no,
you don't release toxins in a sauna.
You sweat, and that gives your
cardiovascular system stress
and, like I said before,
those short term stresses
are really good for your body.
But it has nothing to do
about releasing toxins.
Damree Yarsoneea, Doctor
Mike do doctors listen
to music while performing surgery?
Yeah, they do!
They rock out all the time.
I've been with doctors that listen
to anything from Kenny G jazz to Eminem.
People vibe in the operating
room, we have a good time.
It's all about maintaining, you know,
a good morale amongst both the doctor
and the other health professionals
that are in the room at the same time.
Alyssa Asato, does your heart really stop
every time a person sneezes?
No.
Also, your heart isn't beating like this.
(rapid rumbling)
A person's heart generally beats anywhere
from 60 to 100 beats per minute at rest.
So if they're beating 60 beats per minute,
that's one beat every second, right?
So if you sneeze,
(sneezing)
how would it stop beating?
You mean it'll skip a beat?
No.
Core, core no.
Doctor Mike and Ken Jeong
need a collaboration now.
Now!
I know we need this.
Doctor Ken Jeong, please,
come to thy channel.
Let's talk medicine and have a laugh,
because I've heard a very
wise person once say,
laughter can be medicine?
I usually get all my
questions and comments
from the YouTube videos.
But I wanted to get some
from Twitter this time.
By the way, if you're not
following me, you should,
my username is real
Doctor Mike on Twitter.
Let's tackle some of
these Twitter questions.
Slowtownswift13, how do
you manage to film videos,
edit, and upload them
and work as a doctor?
What are your tips on time management,
love your vids.
Thank you so much.
I don't edit my videos, my man Dan Owens
sitting behind the camera edits the videos
and he's very good at it.
I think part of the success
of the YouTube channel
is my ability to give information
in an easy to understand, relatable way
and then the other part of
it is Dan's rockstar editing.
So without him, this
channel doesn't exist.
How do I manage my time?
Honestly, I just keep going
and involve myself in
all of these activities
that I genuinely love
and am passionate about.
And when I do that, it doesn't feel
like I'm forcing myself to do anything.
I just do it.
I get so much positivity
and feedback from you guys,
from the love that I have for what I do,
and as a result of that,
I stay very motivated.
I recommend that you find
what you love to do as well.
Kierstyn Parker, what do you think will be
a bigger health issue among
Gen Z due to iPhone usage?
Neck pain or bad vision?
The posture of walking
and talking on your iPhone
is really bad for your spine
and people who are walking and texting
and falling into those basement shafts
or walking into traffic, oh
my god, it's so scary for me.
Please, if you're gonna use your phone,
have a seat, use it,
and then live your life.
It's so much better to
limit your screen time
and enjoy the world around you
than constantly to be buried inside here.
Emma Hurter, ah, when are
you starting a podcast?
I know, and I saw the person
that tweeted at me, I don't
know if it was you Emma,
that said we got 20,000 likes
on that podcast comment from the video.
I have looked in to starting a podcast,
I've even worked with a
company in doing this.
We threw around some ideas,
but the amount of time
that needs to be dedicated
to a podcast I feel like isn't worth
the trade off just yet.
Because if I wanna do,
let's say a podcast format
where I have guests on,
or I give you some sort
of long form content,
we could just do it right here on YouTube.
Right now, I'm kind of holding
off on the podcast situation,
I hope you understand.
Please tell my mom that
homeopathic medicine is bogus.
Raul's mom, homeopathic, it shouldn't even
be called medicine, homeopathy is bogus.
Forget about it.
I love answering your guys' questions
and I actually put together a playlist
of my favorite responding
to comments videos.
So click it, and stay happy and healthy.
(light jazzy music )